m
c'est en fanfare et sous une petite
pluie fine que s'est déroulée
l'inauguration de la fête des goyaviers
la plaine des palmistes de nombreux bals
mais plainois voulait être présent pour
débuter les festivités avec les
officiels le défilé qui a démarré devant
la mairie s'est ébranlé jusqu'au champ
de foire situé quelques mètres plus loin
c'est en présence des élus de la
municipalité des représentants du
département et de la région ainsi que
des chambres consulaires que cette
inauguration s'est déroulée la fête du
goyavier l'occasion pour le petit fruit
rouge de montrer tout son potentiel
économique
un potentiel que défend sylvie mon nom
président de l'association des
producteurs notre goyaviers on est
arrivé à 120 ans avec
disons avec en fil du temps on a
commencé que cinq petites heures
aujourd'hui
il a pris parce que 20
vingtaine de producteurs sur les lignes
ça peut être sur la peine de
bannissement
salazie sur le prend en compte on a eu
la volonté de créer cette fille de
gravier pour que ce soit quant à trier
pour que ce soit qu'on soit considérée
comme ils peuvent et producteur de
goyavier et et cette filiale était
nécessaire parce que pourquoi d'autres
fruits
on nous fait il ya bien organisés et le
kayak est en fait combien niveau des
prix surtout quand on vendait c'était
vraiment des prix vraiment bas il alors
que l'autre allait ramasser des
goyaviers c'est pas comme cueillir vie
des habitants de cinq ans le goyavier
qui se décline sous toutes les formes et
même s'il s'est fait un peu plus rares
cette année sa richesse pourrait générer
de nombreux emplois
elle a une grosse grosse de monde que
nous en tant que producteurs n'arrivent
pas à satisfaire parce que
on a des qui savent à la demande
vraiment global it one entre 120 et 150
de temps et nous ne veut pas ne peut pas
fournir vraiment
vous passerez à ce logiciel la solution
c'est d'abord d'avoir des terrains
étaient mentalement de d'agrandir à nous
en tant que producteur d'avoir d'autres
jeunes qui est à la 9e
en janvier un plan dans la protection de
guerriers manger un fruit en confiture
transformer en jus ou encore en
culinaria uru le collier vielles peut
également agrémenté des caries bien de
chez nous mais depuis quelques années le
conseil départemental a fait de cette
peste végétale une vraie richesse avec
des objets fabriqués en bois de goyavier
elle a déjà permis la création peu plus
d'une cinquantaine d'emplois en
insertion qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux
seront pérennisés au sein d'une société
coopérative dont ils ont eux mêmes
propriétaires
aujourd'hui c'est déjà 500 tonnes de
bois de goyavier qui chaque année sont
d'assez valoriser un vrai potentiel
économique qui à travers la création de
l'atelier départemental a permis
l'embauché de nombreuses personnes
la fête des goyaviers un moyen de
promotionner le goyavier mais également
les produits qui en découlent autre
saveur mon négligeable de la réunion le
miel pas encore au beau y aviez il ne
reste plus aux apiculteurs car relever
le défi